[Music]
let me decide what i care about i just
wanted to see the pizza dog again but no
six days into christmas and we're gonna
fill it with a lot of christmas
activities
thanks previously on segment now i know
the gingerbread house will play a
prominent role in this episode because
you reminded us of it spoiler culture
has gone too far wasn't all of this at
the end of the last episode it's like
the 90 seconds of previously on before
the opening logos wasn't enough so you
had to do another 20 seconds after them
for a total of two and a half full
minutes before we even get to any new
content a decision made even worse by
the fact that this episode released at
the same time as episode 1. we don't
need all this refresher of something we
just saw i don't know who herman hired
for his graphics but this is a terrible
representation of a piece of pizza come
to herman's where you can get a single
giant pepperoni a random mushroom in
what might be toenail clippings on every
slice i uh started taking martial arts
when i was five wow it's like a year ago
hayley steinfeld's a 25 year old woman
so you can just go ahead and [ __ ] all
the way off with that condescending
noise so that that's how you operate
you're just constantly looking for
things that are suspicious or weird
actual footage of friends and family
attempting to understand my job somehow
makes its way into the show um you know
some some people have actually called me
the world's greatest archer being
arrogant enough to play people have been
saying bragg oh he's not my dog dog
napping so what all did you do in this
suit that is a personal question sir
you're kind of my favorite avenger are
you okay by the way clearly not did you
hear what you just said there's at least
a concussion at play here the tracks
just must have followed you from the
auction to where i found you which
reminds me how did hawkeye find her in
the first place does he have tracking
tech left over from avenger days
announcing yourself five full seconds
before attacking if they didn't wear the
tracksuits we could have gone with
cliched bad guys who make sure our
heroes have time to crack a joke and get
out of the way suit mafia my favorite
part of the episode is watching hawkeye
and this kid with a [ __ ] bow just
casually walk down the fire escape in
plain view of the tracksuiters in the
pizza joint owners i mean we don't see
when they descend from above and come
out from the front of the building but
that has to be what happened right why
else would they be walking in the front
of the building like this
is is he swiping all these supplies for
the single cut on his forehead one tube
must be enough and why does she need
this much rubbing alcohol this is too
much even for people who are wanting to
make their own hand sanitizer stocking
your goldfish near the wound closure
tape why yes clint you may enter my
apartment she says to clint while
currently standing in someone else's
apartment without permission
good thing hawk i knew about the age-old
tradition of firemen leaving their
jackets directly by open fire truck
doors and their helmets on the front
bumper it's that hero college education
finally paying off
i don't want to spend the next half hour
researching whether or not fire
departments allow personalized stickers
on their work vehicles so instead i'm
going to send this plot convenience
sticker and send anyone who would want
to advertise their nerdness so boldly
since when did everybody start saying i
love you to everybody all the time
cynicism this much first aid chaos for
that little cut you did it all wrong
let me fix you is the idea that after
years of combat training kate wouldn't
know how to apply a band-aid to her
forehead correctly way to undermine the
intellect and basic problem-solving
skills of your brilliant female lead i'm
just gonna rip it off [ __ ] band-aid
okay it is a band-aid there is no way
that this man just typed nyc la erpers
by tapping his thumbs in the same place
on the keyboard over and over again
let's fix this let's figure out what he
really wrote
well that's dumb the most miraculous
thing about the ronin gear is that it
magically fits every body type head in
the mode eat your heart out
again
fine we'll fix this one too
no donuts buddy forbidding donuts i may
be an idiot but i got seniority middle
management is this about the ninja no
it's not about the ninja lying to your
children these two events have officials
wondering if indeed the ronin has
returned to new york city we're now two
for two on episodes with forced news
position i'm not counting my arrows
before they quiver but hawkeye may be
trying to shoot the moon here and get
news position into every episode it's
risky because it's a sin every time but
if they pull it off we'll be forced to
take 50 sins off in the final episode
we'll keep you updated you're just not
going to listen to me are you why would
she she's not a child and she barely
knows hawkeye if the show thinks that
his clout should weigh in on his ability
to boss other people around they should
have done a better job at making us
believe that anyone gives a [ __ ] about
who hawkeye even is go get changed
he looks silly easy there clint you just
combined a man orders a woman around
with a woman should look a certain way
you aren't careful we're going to think
you're a legitimate [ __ ] instead of
this weird half-hole thing the show
seems to be trying to do what am i
selling then huh it's certainly not
halloween costumes and toys off the
shelf inspiration but also pretty much
solely for the halloween costumes and
toys off the shelf because disney hey
what are you wearing
oh they said um
a friend's being ashamed to admit you're
friends with david s pumpkins she feels
threatened by me and you know what
i can understand why is it because
you're a one note character that's
painted so thin you can still see the
drywall behind you because
and if you break the rules
it's gonna get real messy but why would
hawkeye care about what the police
officers and firefighters think if he
breaks the larp rules or is he afraid
they'd beat him up for disrupting their
adult playtime for a very real threat is
no one allowed to be an actual adult
during larp time is it a you have to be
in character until midnight situation
because those rules are broken
immediately when grylls has a quick chat
with hawkeye out of character and they
work it out certainly everyone here
would be all about helping hawkeye solve
a real threat but the show's got a larp
i guess so your scrotum tells your
character's mission by god's bones look
at that starting scroll it's like a
heavy duty parchment with flame detailed
edges and fancy calligraphy instructions
and you're saying every player gets one
of these who's financing this buffer
elon musk what are the rules here can
everyone swarm one person and eliminate
them everyone seemed paired up a moment
ago so how do you know when to switch to
free-for-all i'm asking because the
show's confusing me not because i want
to do it or anything so is it just like
a torso hit that takes you out like when
would i know how to like fake an injury
and then like fall to a knee before
rising up and shoving my pretend sword
through my enemies thigh in this really
dumb confusing game you're a superhero
in real life discounting that you are a
real life superhero as a firefighter and
i fought thanos yeah and i'm sure that
after i spun out and told my car trying
to avoid an idiot driver that the bug
that happened to hit my rear windshield
right before the spin reveled at the
chaos he thought he caused too hawkeye's
adorable again
see you tomorrow
the phone makes the hang up noise but
kate didn't hang up and neither did the
officer so who's the third person on the
line and why is it pizza dog
you must drink the ritualistic portion
it is a bottle event has the cash for
multiple banners tens props and costumes
but when the call came through for a
bottle they were all like what do you
think we're made of money you mime that
[ __ ] wendy can't have that show up on my
credit card no they they will charge
which brings the question how was
hawkeye not charged to play already can
anyone walk in and laugh for free until
midnight how are funds collected how is
the group funded who is paying to rent
out a spot in central park boring i
already knew this was coming because of
the previously on and now it means
nothing to me okay all she said was why
not that's not a convincing argument
that's not an argument at all i was
going to say norma bates would be
excellent at tv sends and such but then
i thought is why not an argument so then
i decided that actually it could be a
valid argument and that she's wrong here
and therefore not excellent at tv sends
but since i've already started sinning
this i might as well go ahead and give
this in anyway because well
why not is is this my first rich person
has fencing gear at the ready cliche how
many people get murdered by a sword each
year in new york well technically swords
are classified as cutting instruments
and lumped with knives and such because
let's face it knives are really just
tiny swords so quick search says about
thirty percent of murders in new york
are by swords of varying sizes so maybe
just open up google for a second okay
before throwing jack's good name under
the bus
oh
no not a simple butterscotch that was at
a dead person's house one time and could
have been handed to jack 12 different
non-nefarious ways kate bishop
not key bishop k bishop is guy bro okay
bishop is not guy did hawkeye just take
a right turn into deadpooly and
silliness is the tone whiplash is real
bro and rinner could really work on his
ryan reynolds impersonation
bro i found her and he knows this how he
can't see her face and only moments ago
he thought kate was a dude
whoa a person that's probably important
in the comics but i don't know just
ended the episode by breaking the fourth
wall and looking right at me however
could i stop watching now
you have terrible aim would a bag of
money know a place if a girl says her
name a man will feed her tonight a girl
has no name beginners only get one free
hit if you get here in the torso it's
fatal
let us gingerly touch our tips
well i'm a viking i'm i'm really a
viking i don't care
you ready i was born ready
stop letting me win because i know
something you don't know i am not
left-handed put one foot in front of the
other baby steps